hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game where i will be playing
against
maya chess in the previous video i did a
very short introduction
uh some five minutes about uh what
matches is and
if you're interested in that do check
out my previous video it will be the
first thing you see in the description
below along with some of the links uh
regarding this project
now in the previous video i faced my
chess at a rating of fifteen hundred
uh sorry at eleven hundred uh although
her actual rating was somewhat closer to
fifteen 1500 unleaches
and now i'm testing the the strongest
one it's uh
my chest 19 1900 and
i think the official one is let me just
check uh 1962 but i will put a link to
this game also in the description below
now if you want to check uh check out
the original
so uh without further ado let's check it
out this time i have the white pieces uh
and i open with
e4 as i usually do and sorry about that
and uh maya goes for d5 the scandinavian
defense i accept uh and
now knight to f6 going for the for the
sort of
modern scandinavian defense not uh
bringing the queen out too early
and i'm not a fan of defending the pawn
so i just uh
continue my development knight f3 i give
back the pawn
knight captures on d5 and now i go with
the d4
preparing c4 and further development
with bishop to g4
and here i go c4 uh pushing back the
knight
knight to f6 and now h3 uh saying what
do you want to do with this bishop
bishop to h5 and now uh i go knight to
c3
g4 is actually also very nice here
the strongest move uh in this position
because it allows you to go bishop to g2
immediately
since uh black's queen side is a little
shaky here
uh but okay i went knight to c3 and e6
by maya and i forgot to mention it's
again a three minute game
and here uh there are some games in the
database with the g4 and c5 but i went
queen to b3
and it is a new move already as of move
eight
uh so i'm attacking the the b7 pawn and
allowing bishop captures on f3
maya not interested defends the pawn
with b6 and here i just bring the knight
to e5
we have bishop to d6 and i go bishop to
d3
continuing my development and here it
seems like you can
win some material with queen captures
but not really because after queen
captures
uh my phone captures the knight and it's
uh it it's a fine
a fine position for white black doesn't
really have anything this is covered
uh this is covered by the knight so not
not really in any danger
so uh maya goes castles here and uh i go
knight to g4 and here i'm preparing
bishop to g5 to attack uh well to pin
the
the attack piece uh and here maya does
a pretty bad move she plays bishop
captures on g4
which means she grabs a pawn but she
opens up my h file and this is just
this is just terrible for black so h
captures ng4
knight captures and now i capture on h7
with check
king to h8 and here i don't go bishop to
e4 to go for the rook
i'd rather go bishop here and i thought
it was enough to
you know get get a mating attack because
i'm either winning back
winning the night here or after knight
to h6 which was played in the game
i captured with the bishop g captures
and now i played
rook captures on h6 with king to g7
attacking my rook
and i just continued the king hunt rook
h7 czech king to f6
and now uh here is a very delicate
position where
i should uh continue properly and by
properly i mean knights to e4 check and
this leads to a
a very quick resolution because after
the king accepts this
then comes queen to h3 with check and
now it's just the game king captures
here
queen to e3 with check king f5 and now
rook to h5 check and that's game king g6
and the queen to h6 check
but it like i said it's a three minute
game i didn't spend a lot of time on on
any of the moves i went back bishop to
h3
i thought what could happen wrong i
could go night stay for check next i
could castle queen side bring the other
rook into the attack
uh and uh it's actually very dangerous
to go back with king to e7 because of c5
and now the bishop is under attack and
also if you react to this queen captures
an e6 is coming
since df pawn will not be able to
capture so i didn't
i didn't really see anything wrong with
retreating my bishop to h3
however there is something wrong with it
as you'll see
uh because maya played king to g6 and
now my rook is trapped on h7
and i'm actually going to use this for
for a thumbnail maybe
maybe i'm not gonna so king g6 my rook
is under attack and i can't go here the
queen guards there
that's where both of these squares are
guarded uh three scores are guarded by
the king this is
covered by the rook so i have to play
something but the rook is lost so here
i played queen c2 check f5 and now
i went for a queenside castle i thought
okay this rook
this rook's a goner i'm just gonna
castle and bring the other rook into the
game however
he there was a very interesting line
again with c5 here
because after captures and captures and
let's say bishop captures or bishop to
e5 doesn't really matter
rook to d1 this is how you bring the
rook into the game queen g5 and now
knight the e4 pretty pretty crazy stuff
and then after i have captured some
queen captures with check it's a it's a
really crazy position king of six and
now g3 threatening f4 and
black just falls apart so this was in
the position i instead uh gave up the
rook went
queen side castles and here we have king
captures on h7
and now uh maya is up a whole rook but
okay
i'm still on the king khan to rook to h1
i'm preparing some nasty discoveries now
with the bishop
so king g7 avoiding the nasty
discoveries and now
g4 like in the previous game i don't
like my position but i want to open up
lines in front of the black king
uh we have queen g5 check by maya i go
back king to b1 and now
knight to c6 bringing the knight into
the game attacking the d4 pawn
and here i capture i just want to open
up lines not really caring about the d4
pawn
captures on f5 and now knight to d5 i
just wanted to bring my
knight as close as possible to the black
king but i don't really have anything
here
uh maya played knight captures on d4 and
i went king c3
pinning the knight bishop to e5 now
black is threatening some discoveries
there aren't uh
all that many nasty discoveries but
still you have to be careful
uh and if i was playing against the
human opponent uh i would probably
resign here but
uh like you've seen in the previous game
i can make some very
very uh well uh dubious decisions and i
played knight captures on c7
i thought okay maybe she just captures
and then i get uh you know maybe maybe i
can survive a little bit longer
and she did she played bishop captures
on c7 you should just ignore this bring
the rook into the game
but she did capture it and now i played
the queen captures on d4 and it's still
not a problem black is still
much better here queen to f6 i played
rook g1 check
and now you have to go back with king to
h8 it seems uh
like an odd thing to do putting the king
on such a lonely square cut off
from the entire board but this is
actually the way to go for black instead
my played king to f7 and now uh the game
is uh well the game is completely
winning for white
so feel free to pause the video and win
the game for me
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on winning the
black queen and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's queen
to d7 check
i played queen to d5 check because this
is the first option that i
checked and i saw it was winning so i
didn't go for queen to d7 one
but you still win the win the queen so
it's not a problem uh we have
a queen to e6 here if you move the king
with king to e7
just rook the e1 check and now it's just
crushing you have to give up the queen
and that's it
so instead maya played queen to e6
blocking the check this way but now of
course as you can imagine
rook to g7 check king to f6 if you
capture it then the queen is lost but
now just
rook to g6 check and now i forcefully
win the queen
captures captures this comes with check
and now rook to f6
but i can just capture on f5 which i did
uh king to g5 and now queen to e4 going
after the rook here
and the problem with uh trying to save
the rook is i have this
uh well a very very sneaky attack here
king h6 check
queen h4 checking has to go back now i
go queen h7 check and win the bishop so
that's not an option
so after queen to e4 i uh uh maya played
rook captures on f5 and now i played
queen capture 78 and now the position is
objectively winning
uh she played a few more moves rook
captures on f2 but now
just queen to g8 to check and now
whatever the king goes i'm either gonna
win the
win the bishop well not there obviously
i'm gonna take the rook but if something
like this i'm just gonna win the bishop
so uh she played this and then i played
just queen to f8 to check king e5 and
now i grabbed the rook as well
so bishop to d6 the game continued uh uh
for for a few more moves i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna analyze this because it's
it's a queen against the bishop so we're
just gonna you know
take it all the way she made me work for
for my meal so that's that's fine
uh i'm used to that uh but okay queen
captures on d7 i was able to win by
checkmate
and uh maya was even nice enough to say
gg thanks
thanks for playing in the chat on
leeches
uh so yeah uh it was a bit of a
different experience than facing uh the
1100 maya
uh but not not that much
of a harder experience uh it was uh
pretty pretty much the same
i i went uh you know into the opening
well i played well and then i got a
winning advantage very early on
but that then that uh weird weird
situation where i thought
that every everything was perfectly fine
uh but then it turns out it wasn't
here where i just retreated with the
bishop to h3 planning on
just finishing the attack attack uh
afterwards but after this i just
completely missed my rook was was
trapped and then i had to
you know really really try and get back
into the game and like i said if i
played this against the human opponent i
would have resigned
but i was able to trick her with that uh
knight captures on c7 move so you know
never resign because it happens to human
opponents as well
uh so that's uh that's the game once
again i do hope you enjoyed it uh like i
said if you're interested
more about my chess do check out the
previous video as well
uh where i talk a bit more about about
the entire project
and also if you haven't checked it out
check out that game
uh so yeah uh once again hope you hope
you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank dylan streeter uh
campiano victor
uh lofter amundsen brandon chu and brent
shulman for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day